pakistan right now is in a
constitutional crisis at the national
assembly this was going to be the big
day
where the according to parliamentary
norms according to democratic values the
prime minister was going to show his
numbers and the opposition was going to
show their numbers saying that they have
more people now who oppose imran khan
and he needs to go imran khan has been
hinting towards what he calls an
international conspiracy which has been
rejected by the opposition
pakistan imran khan's party's law
minister also resigned to join ranks
with the opposition and he gave the
charge of the law minister to one of his
very close aides who now when he went to
the assembly invoked article 5 of the
constitution saying that the basis of
this no confidence vote was a foreign
conspiracy and that needs to be debated
what is very interesting here is the
role of pakistan's very strong military
which the opposition had called that it
is
favoring imran khan it is the power that
brought imran khan into his position of
power
and now the military seems to have taken
a step back and that is why the
opposition was able to break away so
many of the people who go for a vote of
no confidence so far we've seen the
military insist that it is going to
remain out of politics in pakistan it
does not favor any side and it is going
to remain neutral and that is where
imran khan's party has been crying foul
as well and saying that the military
should stand with imran khan in the face
of this international conspiracy and we
heard just yesterday from pakistan's
military chief going on the opposite
direction of imran khan whereas he's
been supporting russia he's been trying
to mend ties with russia and going
against a tirade against the united
states and european allies where the
army chief went out in public addressed
a gathering and said that pakistan
remains allied with the united states
and goes with the international
community to condemn russia for its
invasion of ukraine so all of this
playing into
what seems to be a wide constitutional
crisis the military's role again the
military has been saying it wants to
stay out of power and the history of
pakistan is that the military in a
number of coups has been involved in the
politics of power so it remains to be
seen what the military will do there
have been behind the scenes calls that
have been happening there are meetings
that have been done between leaders of
the opposition and military leaders and
meetings between the prime minister and
the chief
of pakistan's intelligence agency and
the army chief so it remains to be seen
what is going to be happening next
you